the New Year offers an opportunity to
assess and improve a lot of things in
our lives including finances to help us
with that we are joined by Financial
Wellness expert and Mentor Lisa Chastain
Lisa it is always good to have you with
us thanks for being here I'm so grateful
to be here Kendall so this is a good
time for people to kind of take note of
what's going on financially in their
world and and make some changes possibly
oh my gosh it money is so stressful yeah
and what we want to do is help families
Focus Less on the stress and more on
what do I do about it this is the best
time of year for you to take an
assessment on what's really important to
you and your family and make necessary
adjustments and some of those
adjustments that you talk about is
having more than one account when it
comes to banking this is really magical
or you may not think about it at first
this way but the envelope system is
really kind of on its way out especially
a lot of businesses these days aren't
even taking cash so how do you make that
work plus I think a lot of people are
nervous to have cash sitting around
their house
I'm horrible with cash I'll tell you
that right but one of the things that I
think really messes us up as families is
that we're banking out of one account
still all the money goes into one
account all the money is going out of
that account and you're running a debit
card out of that account at the same
time you can save yourself a lot of
stress and headache if you separate your
money out even into just one new account
you've got one account that you pay your
bills out of and you've got one account
that you spend out of it's a lot easier
for you to track your money and get a
handle on what's going on you also say
it's important to consciously make a
commitment to make these changes it is
it's so important if you don't know why
you're doing what you're doing
especially when it comes to money you'll
feel lost listen money isn't sitting
around stressing about you it's not
thinking about you or your feelings
you're the director you're the one
that's telling it where to go so by
being being conscientious about what's
important to you and having a game plan
that'll set you up for success for a
long time to come I was telling you
beforehand we started here that I love
your social media because you're always
very positive and upbeat and have some
great messages just about life in
general which I really appreciate and on
top of that you talk about uh having
hope and positivity when it comes to
finances and yet you also say it's
important to prepare for the unexpected
you have to prepare for the unexpected
if the last three years haven't taught
us anything and really like 2008 to you
know all the all the things that happen
in our world you have got to be in
control of your finances and take
ownership of being the leader in your
life and we know there are going to be
unexpected things that happen this is a
good time of year to say what's
important to me this year what's
important to me in my future and make
that a priority that's what I love about
this time of year so for people who
aren't following you yet on social media
I recommend it first of all where can
they find you Savvy money with Lisa on
Instagram is the best place to find me
all right Lisa it is great having you
here wish you a happy 2023 to you and
your family thank you thanks for all the
great information
we